hallo mein name ist luca und viele
fragen mich immer wenn ich eigentlich am
coolsten finde von der ganzen gegen
hinten deswegen frage ich das heute mal
den clever brava zu beginn erstmal die
anfangs frage die ich immer stelle
welche farbe hat mein pullover ich habe
nämlich heute meinen eigenen world
das fängt ja schon wieder gut anhalts
maul welche farbe hat mein pullover das
sollst du mir sagen das hab ich dich
gerade gefragt du [ __ ] ich gebe ihm
drei antwortmöglichkeiten grau schwarz
oder weiß sitzt gerade jemand neben kiel
kennst du luca erstmal fälle was alte
ich in der hand
übrigens dass der mega witzig war ich
hatte gestern das entwicklerteam für
angeschrieben und vom akinator die haben
sich so bedankt und sagen so die mögen
meinen körper bordvideos voll und wissen
zwar nicht was ich sage aber finden es
voll witzig er hat mir gesagt dass es
davon jetzt auch eine app gibt und ob
ich nicht mal spielen will habe ich
gesagt krieg ich nicht hin weil ich die
app nicht gefunden habe aber egal wir
machen weiter hier mit alles klar
ich frag mal nicht kennst du luca
sondern kennst du von crafter
das war nun aussagekräftige antwort
kennst du ukulele
klar von ungespült kennst du den hund
balu fragezeichen kennst du roman
lochmann
ich hasse diese dummen gegenfragen und
kennst du vitello meinst du dr
bin kurz davor mein pc zu tesche okay
kennst du die gewinnst du online herr
mit für die gäste oder antworte mir
meine fragen clever bot dann können wir
ganz
wer ist der coolste in lukas zimmer ich
natürlich vielleicht müssen wir ihn erst
mal ein wenig auflockern dann fangen wir
erstmal an mit wie geht's
bist du männlich oder weil ich bin
männlich
ich will dass du weiblich berichtigen
man schreibe das weil er das mit
ich stelle jetzt die frage mal ganz
bezieht und zwar ist der coolste von
khomeini balu vitello und luca
wieso unterhalte ich mich dann
eigentlich mit dem was macht eigentlich
überhaupt keinen sinn man kriegt
überhaupt keine antworten ausgleich zum
praktikum gehen deswegen schreibe ich
jetzt mal motiviert mich mal zum
praktikum zu gehen so dass er nicht so
um
aber ich möchte die geschichte von euch
mal hören
von wem der befehl kommt von der usa ich
mache jetzt mal ein bisschen anders und
zwar bekommen wir jetzt alle nummern ich
bin ein kollege ist zwei vitello ist 3
und balu ist vier deswegen schreibe ich
jetzt 1 2 3 oder 4
das ist kein scherz ich muss morgen die
erde verlassen schön kanns mir
vielleicht vor meine frage beantworten
sagt eine zahl zwischen 1 und 4
so und jetzt ziemlich langer name
es gab bisher nahezu keinen satz ohne
rechtschreibfehler 1 2349 understand
[ __ ] you can für sag mir einfach eine
zahl zwischen 1 und 4
das wissen dass ich nach dem aufnehmen
von einer clever bot folge erst mal zwei
wochen therapie muss weil ich so fertig
bin 13 ist nicht zwischen eins und vier
was liegt zwischen 1 und 4 05 da er
gesagt hat das ist 05 05 zwischen a
05 liegt gar nicht zwischen 1 und 2 ich
dorftrottel ich schreibe einfach cool
die balu vitello nein ich fragezeichen
bist du männlicher
nö